one of the dirty secrets of the bitcoin
market over the last couple of weeks is
that miners have been selling yes the
bitcoin miners they're being forced to
sell their bitcoin why were they doing
it well as the price of bitcoin
continued to fall all of their expenses
were still denominated in u.s dollars
and so naturally if the price of bitcoin
is falling and the amount of revenue
they derive from mining is going lower
and lower and lower then of course if
you have us dollar denominated expenses
you have to sell the bitcoin on your
balance sheet to be able to fund those
expenses and so that is exactly what we
saw for weeks and weeks that doesn't
exactly bring a ton of confidence to the
market when they see the bitcoin miners
actually selling their bitcoin every
single time that we have a bitcoin bear
market there's always the foot the
mining death spiral is upon us now of
course we have the difficulty adjustment
which means that miners eventually will
become profitable again but there has
been a reversal in their actions just
recently over the last couple of days we
now see miners not selling but instead
they are starting to accumulate again
you can see this data here from glass
node and so naturally as we see miners
beginning to accumulate that could serve
as a potential signal that we're having
some sort of bottoming effect now miners
they are susceptible to the price of
bitcoin to the difficulty adjustment and
the cost of their electricity but to
have seen them selling so much bitcoin
to see bitcoin's price continue to go
down and now to see these same exact
miners actually buying bitcoin it's very
interesting nick carter was recently on
the podcast and he talked a lot about
all the miners selling especially the
publicly traded ones who had taken on
tons of leverage and had to fund all
their operations if now miners feel
strong enough that they can start to
accumulate rather than sell that either
means that they have really strong
balance sheets or they think that the
market is starting to bottom out
regardless of why they're doing it this
is an important data point because the
miners are a great signal as to what
actually is happening in the market
given that a blockchain is a public
ledger that can be audited by anyone
anywhere in the world it means that we
can see exactly what they're doing at
all times they were selling for weeks
and weeks and weeks but now they're
re-accumulating again and this is part
of the natural market cycle of bitcoin
there's bull markets there's bear
markets and regardless of if you're new
or you've been around for a long time
the bear markets are never fun the fud
just gets replayed over and over again
but somehow someway the new bear market
always happens to have more value than
the last one keep an eye out there watch
what the miners are doing they can tell
us a lot about what's happening in the
market and now that they're
re-accumulating it seems to be a pretty
bullish sign hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time